well now as Boris Johnson and Michael
Gove attacked the Prime Minister's
failure to reduce immigration saying
he's had a corrosive effect on public
trust John Major has in turn accused
their campaign have been crass and
distorted certainly the rhetoric is
ramping up around what Tony Blair is
calling the most important decision for
Britain since 1945 the current Labour
leader Jeremy Corbyn has almost also not
being immune from it all with some
criticizing him for being somewhat
absent from the scene well his shadow
home secretary Andy Burnham certainly
isn't he joins me now from Lee in
Greater Manchester very good morning to
you mr. Burnham well let's pick through
some of that introduction first of all
the intervention from your former leader
tony blair could that be
counterproductive given his level of
popularity at the moment in the country
no of course people will listen to a
former Prime Minister including sir john
major who said something similar today
doma i think you know to X prime
ministers that carries a lot of weight
doesn't it and you know you hear these
comments today from Mr Gove and mr.
Johnson well to be honest I would say
back to them you're all dishonest
because you stood on a pledge in your
manifesto on immigration under which
there was no clear plan so don't come
that now at this at this stage of the
stage of the game I think what we're
seeing is the leaves side having had
their economic case collapse around them
are now scaremongering on immigration
and it's not a pittance but I mean on
this issue of the Prime Minister's
pledge to get net migration down to the
tens of thousands it's something labour
never did do you believe that the Prime
Minister has has left himself wide open
on the remain side because of that I
think he was wrong dermot to make that
pledge because in or out of the European
Union I think it would be hard to see
how it could be delivered any time soon
because this is what the leave side
won't say if they say they want to do a
deal for Britain with the European Union
as Norway has found there will be
conditions about free movement that come
with that deal that's why I say they're
being dishonest and their and their
scare mongering yeah of course there are
legitimate concerns about migration
levels of my
Gration pressure on public services
pressure on wages I speak a lot about
those things because I recognize those
as real concerns my message to voters
though in these final days is those
concerns don't outweigh the much bigger
risk to our economy if we choose to
leave and that is a risk that is clearly
spelt out today on the front page of The
Observer by ninety percent of economists
questioned we never get such unanimity
among economists but we are getting it
on this question Britain's economy will
be damaged if we vote to leave and I
think that message now is really
beginning to get through what do you say
to those within your own party who are
making the assessments at this point
that it is you're so you're sounding
pretty confident there that you know the
economic arguments been won there for
that's probably the lynchpin of winning
the the whole thing that the campaign to
remain is done they think you're a
Labour supporter you don't like the
Conservatives and they seem to be like
fighting fighting like cats in the sack
let them get on with it and hence that
explains mr. Corbin's rather lukewarm
interventions well you might remember
last year when I stood for the Labour
leadership i propose that labor should
have a separate in campaign and I'm very
glad that was one of the things I said
last year came to pass and we set that
up and led superb Lee by Alan Johnson
and that has been able to make the
argument and if you take an issue like
immigration which is a difficult issue
in many labor areas the challenge for us
is to take on board people's legitimate
concerns but at the same time to remind
people that this is a mixed picture
immigrations a two-way street there were
figures out in the middle of last week
showing that over 400,000 younger Brits
are working abroad around Europe and
also i always say to many of my
constituents yeah how many older people
like to have a couple of months away in
the warmer parts of europe in the winter
you know I'm sorry benefit from only
interesting sorry shadow him say only
interrupting because that wasn't the
question the question was about to
labour voters who want to remain making
the assessments that they feel the
campaign is going well to remain there
for for the rest of the time available
let the Conservatives fight it out
amongst
themselves and labor may profit oh sorry
I'd miss heard your question Dermot well
I would say absolutely not you know this
is bigger than party politics isn't it
that last the old that's the
straightforward answer to your question
I would say that to everybody the vote
that people cast in just over three
weeks time will be the single most
important vote they will ever cast in
their adult life because it will
determine Britain's position in the
world you know how we see ourselves how
the rest of the world Caesar so
whichever way people vote this is is
utterly crucial so it goes way beyond
the color herbs and flows of party
politics it is about deciding what kind
of country we want to be how we see
ourselves in the 21st century is that
serious and to be honest with you I
think at times the quality of the debate
hasn't risen to the occasion it's not
been good enough and it hasn't given
people the clarity and the facts that
they're after and hopefully in these
last few weeks that will come through
and I hope people will put fairly narrow
party political considerations aside and
what do you think of this you know from
the back bencher within the Conservative
Party Andrew bridgen saying that even if
the remain side win and especially if it
happens narrowly the party will come
gunning for Mr Cameron the Prime
Minister could be removed he said we
could face a general election in the
autumn is your party ready for that is
jeremy corbyn ready for it well we're
ready whenever it comes dermot but i
would say to mr. bridgend that I think
he's part of the problem internal
squabbling at a moment like this is
turning the public off people want to
see the issues debated what will happen
to jobs if we leave what will happen to
our security people want a proper debate
a quality debate about those things they
don't want to see politicians
positioning themselves for what might
come after its this question is bigger
than all of that and that would be my
message at this moment in time look at
what's at stake look at the risks to our
economy that being pointed out today
focus on the big picture not the the
sideshows are taking place all over the
although all around us and on the basis
of the bigger picture and
strategic interest of our country vote
to remain on the twenty-third of Jim
shadow home secretary thank you very
much indeed Andy Burnham there thank you